c'est à l'étagé de cette petite maison
située au quartier bellevue à trinité au
domaine petit galion qu'un corps sans
vie
sévèrement brûlé a été retrouvé le 10
décembre dernier
comme constaté par les techniciens en
investigations criminelles et les
secours dépêchés sur place les flammes
ont ravagé les différentes pièces
beaucoup de questions restent pour le
moment sans réponse
les parents du propriétaire des lieux
sont perplexes pour l'instant on n'a pas
d'information à part la récupération du
corps qui se trouvent à la morgue en ce
moment donc nous nous n'avons aucune
information à ce sujet et nous attendons
le livre légiste nous donne des
informations pour qu'on puisse avancer
néanmoins depuis l'incendié de cette
petite maison de campagne
un homme anti-culture de profession père
de cet enfant n'a pas donné signe de vie
de plus ses parents précise que vécut de
location qui l'utilisé pour ses
déplacements auraient disparu depuis ce
drame
on a cherché par tous les moyens à
entrer en contact avec lui
tous à sa femme ses enfants nous mêmes
mais jusqu'à présent on n'a pas eu de
contact du tout pour l'heure aucun
élément ne confirme l'identité du corps
comme mentionné à plusieurs reprises par
les avocats du barreau de martinique le
manque de disponibilité de médecins
légistes sur l'île prolongent les délais
d'attentes ce qui accentue la douleur
des membres des familles surtout qu'on
ménage en ménage beaucoup de gens dans
la famille et on ne veut pas que ça dure
trop longtemps parce que ça va finir par
se savoir un prince et à tête
que s'est il passé réellement le 10
décembre dernier au domaine petits
gagnants à trinité enquête diligentée
par le parquet est en cours